ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครู Arty
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนเย้กลัวตี้กูพี่เอ๋ใน
ช่อง Complex  sensible ไทยนะครับวันนี้
ใช่ค่ะวันนี้เรามาเจอกันวันอะไรครับวัน
นี้วันนี้ใช่ค่ะวันอะไรครับขอ Arty
เสียงเท่ห์เลยวันนี้วันจันทร์วันอังคาร
ครับวันอังคารแล้ววันอังคารเสียงคุยกัน
เป็นผู้ชายมาก
แล้วดึกวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 21 ครับ
วันที่ 21 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมิถุนายนครับ
เดือนนี้เดือนมิถุนายนปี 5 ปีพศอะไรคะศ.
แล้วปีพ.คศนะคะมีอะไร
22 ครับค่ะ
แต่ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้เอา 20:00 น
20:00 กี่นาทีเนี่ย 58 นาที
โอ้ยไอ้ห่า
เอ้ยดูใกล้ๆหู
21:00 นแล้วครับอีก 2 นาที
เราก็ยังไม่นอนเนาะถ้ายังไม่นอนยังไม่นอน
ถ้านะควรตี้แถวบ้านกู Arty เป็นยังไงเข้า
วันนี้อาการร้อนฝนตกอากาศอากาศไม่ร้อน
เท่าไหร่ครับตอนนี้ฝนกำลังตกฝนมันตกอ๋อ
ตรงข้ามกับบ้านครูเอ๋เลยค่ะกูอ่ะที่มัน
คุยฝนไม่ตกเหรอครับบ้านบ้านครูเอ๋ฝนไม่ตก
แต่ร้อนมาก
เดี๋ยวจะมาตอนนี้ตกที่บ้านครู Arty ใช่
ไหมคะ
3  4 ชั่วโมงจะมาหมู่บ้านครูเอ๋นะคะผ้า 3
ชั่วโมงควรตี้คิดว่าตบที่นี่หมดแล้วครับ
มีให้ไปป่ะคู่เอ๋แล้วก็บดแล้วเดี๋ยวนี้ลง
พัดมา
น้ำตกเถอะร้อนมากค่ะที่แล้ววันนี้กว่าตี้
จะพาครูเอ๋กับนักเรียนไปเที่ยวที่ไหนคะ
วันนี้เราจะไปจังหวัดอีกจังหวัดหนึ่งที่
เอ่อควรจะร้อน
ฝนตก
ทั้งวันนี้คนที่คิดว่าคนไทยจะไปเที่ยวตอน
ที่อากาศหนาวๆนะอากาศร้อนไม่อยากไปตายเขา
ต้องไปตอนหน้าหนาวๆครับจังหวัดในภาคอีสาน
ครับเขาจังหวัดอะไรคะกว่าตี้จังหวัดเลย
ครับ
จังหวัดเลยจังหวัด
หนาวหรอคะอ่ะหัวหน้าหนาวให้เปล่า
คู๋เคยได้ยินว่าที่เลยน่ะเวลาหนาวนะบางที
0 องศาหรือเปล่า
มีที่ที่ภูกระดึงที่เป็นที่ที่สูงบนภูเขา
อากาศก็จะหนาวมาก
บ้างข้างล่างพื้นที่ข้างล่างก็จะไม่หนาว
เท่าไหร่อ๋องั้นข้างล่างโอเคประมาณ 20
สิงหาคมองศาเซลเซียสแต่งข้างบนข้างบนอาจ
จะ 5  5 หรือ 10 องศาเซลเซียสหรือบางที 0
ประเทศไทยมีนะคะนักเรียนที่ประเทศไทยมี
อากาศหนาวประมาณ 0 องศาเซลเซียสแต่ว่าอาจ
จะ 1 วันสองวันสามวันหมดแล้ว
มา
จังหวัดที่มีอากาศหนาวก็จะเป็นอ่ะที่ที่
อยู่บนภูเขาสูงสูงใช่ภูเขา
สูงอากาศก็จะหนาวมากสู่หักหนาวมาก on เขา
ก็บอกว่ายิ่งสูงยิ่งหนาวใช่ไหมคะยิ่งสูง
ยิ่งหนาวเดี๋ยววันนี้ขวดอีฟพาไปที่
จังหวัดเลยจะพาไปที่อ่ะที่ภูกระดึง
กระดึงที่ภูกระดึงที่อยู่ที่จังหวัดเลย
เป็นเอ่อที่ที่สูงเป็นอันดับสองของประเทศ
ไทยและอันดับ 1 ที่ไหนคะขับดึกอยู่ที่ซอย
อะไรอ่ะนนท์ใช่อยู่ที่เชียงใหม่ศูนย์ใน
ประเทศไทยค่ะ
ขวดตีรู้ไหมครูเอ๋น่ะชอบจังหวัดเลยมากชอบ
มากอีกสวยครับ Top อะไรที่เลยมากครับชอบ
ชอบภูกระดึงนี้ล่ะค่ะ
มีความฝันคิดว่าถ้าโตขึ้นโตขึ้นโตขึ้นและ
ฉันจะไปเที่ยวภูกระดึง
เคหมึก 54 ยังไม่เคยไปเลยค่ะเออ 54 แล้ว
ยังไม่โตเหรอเออ
ไม่มีโอกาสไปผูกนึงอยากไปก็จะเป็นจังหวัด
ที่อยากไปแต่ไม่ได้ไปเขาบอกว่าต้องไปก่อน
อายุมากๆค่ะเพราะว่าต้องเดินใช่ไหมคะต้อง
เดินเดินเดินขึ้นกับต้องเดินขึ้นภูเขาไป
สูงๆคลิปอากริปคลิปนี้เนอะคลิปนี้ถ้าใคร
ชอบเดินไปค่ะไปกับครัวตี้ไม่ต้องเดินเอง
เอาพี่ค่าเดินไปถ้าเราไปดูเหอะอยากจะรู้
โอเคอ่าเดี๋ยวผมออกครัวทิพย์พาไปดูอ่ะผู้
เขาที่เป็นที่เราเขาเรียกว่าเป็นภูกระดึง
ก่อนเห็นไหมตรงนี้เป็นภูเขาภูกระดึง
เห็ดอันนี้ภาพอะไรคะเนี่ยอ้าเป็นภาพจาก
มุมสูงมองลงมาจากเครื่องบินมองลงมาจากดาว
เทียมเราจะเห็นภาพผู้ก็เล่นเป็นภูเขาภู
เขาเป็นรูปหัวใจอยู่ตรงนี้ครับอ๋อ
โอ๊ะโอ๋ๆดึงนะนักเรียนนักเรียนอันนี้คือ
คืออะไรคืออยากรู้ยังทำไมคุยอยากไปก็บอก
ว่าที่นี่เนี่ยถ้าไม่มีแฟน
ถ้าไม่มีแฟนคุณไปภูกระดึงกลับมาจะได้แฟน
หรอครับแต่ถ้ามีแฟนแล้วไม่ต้องไปชมเมิง
กลับมาจะเลิก
อาจจะแต่งงานหรืออาจจะเลิกกันเพราะว่าการ
เดินขึ้นภูกระดึงเหนื่อยมากถ้าเหนื่อยมาก
ใจทรายเข้าเป็นเป็นภูรักมากโพธิ์รัฐหรือ
ภูล้างเขาคูรักวันนี้เข้าใจอย่างนี้นี่
เองเพราะว่าดูจากดูจากนอกโลก
มาดูบนท้องฟ้ามองลงมาบนภูกระดึงเป็นผู้
หัวใจหัวใจนักเรียนอยากจะไปแล้วเนี่ยฮ่าๆ
ๆโอเคครับๆเดี๋ยวกลัวตี้พาไปเอ่อตอนที่
เราไปเนี่ยบนภูเขาเนี้ยความสูงความสูงจะ
สูงจากระดับน้ำทะเลประมาณ 1,000 บาท
1,200  80 ประมาณ M  R ไม่ใช่กิโลนะคะ
กิโลครับ
โอเคเราก็อะเดี๋ยวกลัวตี้พาไปนะครับนี่
เวลาที่ไปถึงที่นั่นเราเราอยู่ข้างใต้
เอาขยะมามาถึงที่พัสมาตรงนี้ครับจะมี
จุดที่เราจะต้องเดินขึ้นไปจะเริ่มเดิน
ขึ้นภูเขาจากตรงนี้อ๋อเดี๋ยวๆตรงเป็นรูป
หัวใจคืนด้านบนสุดใช่ไหมคะอยู่บนแต่ตรง
จุดข้างล่างคือตรงเขียวแล้วก็ออก 2 ตามๆ
น้ำตาลตรงนั้นใช่ครับตรงนี้เป็นภาพพื้น
ค่ารถไปได้เป็นบ้าอยู่ข้างล่างค่ะ
ความพิเศษของภูกระดึงก็คือควรพิเศษอะไรคะ
บนภูเขาจะเป็นพื้นที่ราบเหมือนกันค่ะย่า
คนที่วาดให้ดูถ้าเป็นพื้นข้างล่างพื้น
ข้างล่างก็จะเป็นแบบนี้ใช่ไหมพื้นค่ะขึ้น
ราบแล้วเราก็ขึ้นไปบนภูกระดึงปั๊บก็จะมี
พื้นที่ราบอยู่ข้างบนอีกค่ะอ้าวชอบอยู่
ข้างบนพื้นที่อ้อ
ออกไม่เหมือนทางเชียงใหม่ที่เค้าจะเป็น
แบบนี้จะไปหา 5 เขาแบบนี้นางเอกเชียงใหม่
เดินภูเขาสูงขึ้นในแบบนี้ค่ะเป็นลักษณะภู
เขาที่ไม่เหมือนกันนะคะอันนี้เป็นลักษณะ
ภูเขาของทางอีสานเลยสายขาถ่างภาคอีสาน
[เพลง]
โอเคเดี๋ยวเราเดินขึ้นไปข้างบนเนี้ยระยะ
ทางประมาณ 5 กิโลเมตรนิดเลยไอ้ๆโคโยตี้
กิโลเมตรนะ 5 กิโลเมตรครับถ้าเดิน
ช้อปปิ้งอ่ะ 5 กิโลเมตรทางราบนะโอเคนะคะ
ขึ้น 5 กิโลเมตรโอเคค่ะเปลี่ยนค่ะ
ไข่เดิน 5 เดินนะคะเดินเอง 5 กิโลเมตร
เดินไหวสบายๆคอมเม้นข้างล่างนะคะไปได้เลย
ถ้าเดินไหวไปได้
ไปเดินขึ้นเดินขึ้นครับควรที่เดินขึ้น
คะค่ะมีอะไรนะกระเช้าลอยฟังขึ้นอ้าไม่มี
กะเฉาไม่มีเงินเช้าใครที่อยากจะขึ้นต้อง
เดินก็แต่ถ้าใครที่ไม่อยากเดินเดินไม่ไหว
เดินไม่ไหวก็มีคนแบบขึ้นไปครับจริงลืม
เปล่าคนแบบขึ้นไปสำหรับใครที่เดินไม่ไหว
ก็จะมีนี่ครับก็มาตั้งแต่ก้างคนให้แบก
ขึ้นไปได้แล้วก็นอนคนนี้เขานอนอ่าน
หนังสือ
เพราะ
ตนเองหัวเราะอะไรรู้ไหมคะตอนนี้กูอัดที่
ให้คุยดูรูปเนี้ยครั้งแรกน่ะกูเอกเอ้ยแบบ
ใครแบกอะไรก็แบบคนเอาแบบคนเนี่ยนอนอยู่
นอนสบายเลยครับอ๋อมีมันเองไปโหเออ
แม็กซ์ผู้ชายของคนที่ต้องแข็งแรงมากๆๆ
หมอเขาสองคนหรือเขามีคนมาเปลี่ยนอ่าสองคน
ครับเขาจะแบ่งกันสอบสองคนแบบขึ้นแล้วก็
แบกลงใช่ครับขึ้น
ขึ้นลง
เขาฟรีไหมคะเลยว่าไม่มีหรอกที่ปีครับต้อง
จ่ายเงินด้วย
[เพลง]
น้ำหนัก 1 กิโลเนี่ย 1 กิโลกรัมเนี่ยเท่า
กับ 50 บาทโห
เอกสารกี่กิโลครับน่าจะ 3,000 ร้อย
นะ 1 แก้ว 50 บาทใช่ไหมคะได้ครับ
3,000  100 บาทนะคะ
ก็ไม่ต้องเดินครับจ่ายเงิน 3,000 บาทช่วง
เดินกู Arty เดี๋ยว 3  1 กิโล 50 บาทนะ
เกิดขึ้นอย่างเดียวหรือขึ้นแล้วก็หมอนัด
ลงใจครับก็ลงขึ้นและลงๆโอเคนะสนใจแต่ถ้า
ขึ้น 3,000 บาทลง 3,000 บาทโอเคคู๋ดู
ยูทูปไม่ไปไม่ไปดีกว่า
โอเคน่าสนใจค่ะนักเรียนค่ะ
ในนั้นคือกูอะตีหรือเปล่าคะไม่ใช่อ่ะกวน
ตีนเดินเองกวนตีนไม่ได้ไม่ได้นอนแปลเพราะ
ว่าแพงไม่อยากเสียเงินเยอะเพราะว่าตียัง
แข็งแรง
แต่กลัวตี้ก็จ้างเขาแบบเหมือนกันเพราะว่า
เอ่อกลัวตี้เนี่ยเอาของกินเอาเต็นท์เอาฮะ
อุปกรณ์ในการพักเต็มขึ้นไปเองค่ะ 5 ใช้
กับก็จ้างเขาแบกไปขอขวดที่เวลาเดินน่ะ
เดินและมีทางเรียบแบบนี้หรือว่าเดินฉัน
ขึ้นอย่างนี้ตลอดเลยอ่าเดินชันตลอดอีก 5
กิโลคู่หนังเรียบนิดหน่อยนี่หน่อยค่ะก็
ได้
แบบนิดหน่อยเอ้าอ๋อ
จะไม่เคยไปอ่ะ
สนุกมากครับสนุกมากบางที่ก็จะมีบันไดองค์
ที่อะนี้ที่ฉันมากๆก็จะมีบันไดให้อ๋อ
มีราวจับเดินขึ้นบันไดได้ค่ะ
เพราะอันนี้ก็เป็นรูปที่ครูอตี้ไปหรือ
เปล่าคะเนี่ยอ้าอันนี้เป็นนักท่องเที่ยว
กลุ่มอื่นครับตอนนี้กลัวที่ไหนเนี่ยคนที่
ถ่ายรูปนิดหน่อยออกค่ะนึกว่าอุปกรณ์ของ
ครู Arty ไม่ใช่ของกวนตีนไม่เยอะขนาดนี้
ครับไม่เยอะ
สงสัยวะถ้าค่าแบบคนนะ 1 กิโลกรัม 1
กิโลกรัม
50 บาทถ้าแปลกของราคาเจอกันไหมคะอ้าว
ราคาเท่ากันเท่ากันก็คือ 1 กิโลกรัม 50
บาท
ถ้าแบบของในคือแบบขึ้น
แล้วก็เขาก็มีสิทธิ์กิโลเข้าแบบขึ้น
500 บาทได้ไหมไม่ใช่ 500 บาท 10 กิโล 500
บาทใช่ 500 บาทอ่ะเขาขึ้นแต่เวลาจะลง
เนี่ยเราต้องจ่ายอีกต่างหากเลยค่ะไม่ต้อง
จ่ายครับก็เหรอหนังเดียวก็ก็ไม่ก็ไม่ไม่
ไม่แพงนะ
ไม่ต้องเอาของที่ไม่จำเป็นขึ้นไปเยอะกับ
ใครให้พี่จำเป็นก็จ่ายไม่ๆมาขาค่ะเว็บกวน
พี่ไปกี่วันไป 2 วันซ้อน 2 วันหน่อยค่ะก็
มีเป็นมีน้ำมีอาหาร
อาหารอาหารครัวตี้ไม่ได้เอาขึ้นไปเพราะ
ว่าข้างบนข้างบนยอดดอยมีร้านอาหารค่ะ
ก็มีม้านั่งหมูกะทะมีร้านขนมของกินเยอะ
ชายไม่ได้จริงหรือเปล่า
มี
เบาะตอนที่ครูเอกเป็นเด็กๆค่ะนั้นนานมาละ
ก็ไม่มีเขาบอกว่าที่คุยไม่ไปเพราะว่าถ้า
ขึ้นไปคุณต้องมีอาหารแล้วแบบอาหารขึ้นไป
คุยกันเลยไม่ได้ไปนะคะเดี๋ยวนี้เดี๋ยวนี้
ไม่ต้องแบกขึ้นไปข้างบนมีอาหารขาย
ดีค่ะจะแพงแพงกว่าซื้อข้างล่างนิดหน่อย
แพงกว่านิดหน่อยน้ำเปล่าขวดละเท่าไหร่ห้า
โหขวดตีจำไม่ได้และน้ำปั่นแพงกว่าประมาณ
20% ก็เหรอลูกก็ประมาณ 10  10  10 กว่า
บาทห้าสิบกว่าบาทที่บางที่เขา 20 เลย 20
หรือไม่ก็สามสิบบาท
[เพลง]
คนแบบเก่งเดี๋ยวข้อนี้นะคะช่วยแบบขึ้นไป
ถ่ายจ่ายถ้าไม่มีคนแบบเดินไม่ไหวบอกว่า
เดิน 5 กิโลกรัมค่ะเมื่อค.ศ.ตัวตีขึ้นมา
ถึงข้างบนแล้วครับเมื่อไหร่เปล่านี่ก็นี้
กวนตี้ค่ะแล้วก็ครอบครัวนะคะไรครับอ่ามี
ลูกชาย 2 คนและก็ภรรยาอีกหนึ่งคนนะคะ 5
โอเคไงลูกบอกว่าเหนื่อยไหม
ลูกลูกยังเด็กอยู่ยังวิ่งเล่นสนุกอยู่ไม่
นอนไม่พออ้า
เหนื่อยไหมคะพี่ก็เหนื่อยนิดหน่อยค่ะ
จีน่าวิ่งวิ่งบ่อยก็เลยไม่เหนื่อยได้ใช่
เพราะกลัวที่ออกกำลังกายบ่อยแต่หาภรรยา
กวนพี่หมดเหนื่อยมาก
เอง
ผู้หญิงเวลาไปมีกระเป๋าตัวเองเด้อมี
แฟนสามีฝากกล้วยถือหน่อย
ก็บอกว่าที่เป็นภูรักเพราะว่าถ้าผู้หญิง
เหนื่อยเราก็แฟนช่วยเอามาผมถือให้ช่วยจน
ไปถึงข้างบนน่ะผู้หญิงจะฟูผู้ชายใจดี
ขอบคุณขอบคุณนะคะใช่ค่ะ
เวลาที่ขึ้นมาถึงข้างบนแล้วขึ้นมาถึงบน
ยอดของภูกระดึงแล้วบนข้างเมื่อกี้ที่ควร
ที่บอกว่าเป็นพื้นที่กว้างใช่ไหมค่ะกวาง
เราต้องเดินไปที่จุดที่กางเต็นท์ออกไกล
ไหมคะอีกประมาณประมาณกี่กิโล
40 กิโลก็สรุปว่าเราจะต้องเดิน 9
กิโลกรัมไปครับ 9 กินบวกข้างบน 4 กิโล
เป็นทางเรียบครับเดินสบายทางราบเลยใช่ไหม
อ่ะให้เดินสบายครับเดินชมผู้ชมไม้ชม
ธรรมชาติไปได้เลยซะนี่แหละที่จะไม่คิดมัน
กิโลกรัมและแท็กขวดตีใหม่จากข้างล่างรถ
ถึงข้างบนยังไม่เดินไปที่การเป็นนะคะจาก
ข้างล่างแล้วขึ้นมาข้างบนน่ะครับใช้เวลา
กี่ชั่วโมงใช้เวลาประ
มาน 3-4 ชั่วโมงเขา
ชั่วโมง
คือกูอะตีนะคะนักเรียนมีใช้มากกว่านี้
ด้วยใช่ไหมบางคนบางคนเค้าใช้หลายชั่วโมง
แล้วใช้ 5-6 ชั่วโมง 5 คนดิค่อยๆเดินค่อย
ๆเดินเหนื่อยก็นั่งพักค่ะได้ว่ามีมีจุด
แบบ
ยังไม่ถึงข้างบนน่ะขึ้นไปแล้วก็มีจุดพัก
ใต้มีจุดพักถ้าไม่ไหวก็หลงใช่
มีจุดพักอยู่ประมาณเดี๋ยวปวดตี้คิดว่ามี
อยู่ประมาณ 5  5  5 จุด me  Some เขาจะ
เรียกเป็น some  some แทรก some
หลายๆอย่างให้กวนพี่จำชื่อไม่ได้และเป็น
ที่พักระหว่างทางใน 5 กิโลนั้นค่ะคือก็
จับได้ 3 แหกเพราะคนที่ไปคนที่ไปบอก
ว่าสมัยก่อนก็เดินเองแล้วพี่คนนึงไปถึง
ซำแฮกแล้วก็บอกเพื่อนไปเหอะฉันจะลง
เหนื่อยอ่ะเหนื่อยฮ่ากรอบบอกดู
[เพลง]
อะไรมีคนแบบ
จากทุกๆซ้ำก็จะมีอาหารขายมีน้ำผลไม้มีน้ำ
อัดลมมีไอติมขายอร่อยขาดหายเพื่อให้เรา
เพิ่มพันหลังมีค่าเดินขึ้นไป
ดีมากน่าสนใจนะคะ
ที่ไปมาเมื่อไหร่คะเนี่ยต่อไปมา 2 ปีที่
แล้วครับอ่าสองปีที่แล้วได้โอเคเดี๋ยว
กว่าที่บอกต้องเดินต่ออีก 4 กิโลเมตรๆ
เดินตอน 4 กิโลเมตรไปถึงจุดที่กางเต็นท์
ครับจะไปเต้นสีเดียวกันหมดเลยนะเต้นท์ของ
อุทยานคนแค่ไม่มีเต็นท์ไปก็ไม่ต้องแบบ
ขึ้นไปไม่ต้องจ้างแต่ไปไปเช่าเต็นท์
อุทยานประมาณ 200  250  300 มีอ๋ออ้าว
แสดงว่าภูกระดึงแบบเป็นอุทยานแห่งชาติใช่
มั้ยได้ครับ
อุทยานก็คือเป็นสวนเป็นภูเขาป่าเป็นต้น
ไม้เนี่ยหันก็เป็นอุทยานแห่งชาติกับของ
ประเทศไทยเทพใช่อ๋อเขาก็จะมีมีมี
ออฟฟิศเนาะของอุทยานก็ไม่เต็นท์เขามีบ้าน
ให้ผักเนี่ยอ่ะบ้า
ยินดีครับมีครับแต่มีไม่เยอะมีหน้าต้อง
จองต้องโทรไปจองก่อนแล้วก็ราคาก็จะแพง
กว่าฮือเต้นใช่ครับเป็นหนึ่งคืนเท่าไหร่
คะภาษาปเนี่ยอ่า 1 คืนอะควรที่เคยไปเคยไป
ถามเนี่ยเขาอยู่ที่ประมาณ 200 บาทก็ไม่
แพงแพงไม่แพง 200 ไม่แพงถ้าบ้านเนี่ย
สตาร์ทที่ 500 บาทนะคะจะไปผิด
บ้านควรที่คิดว่าน่าจะสัก 800
800 ถึงอัน 500 ขึ้นอยู่กับว่าเราได้
ง่ายด้วยให้ดีไม่กินหลังนะมีบ้านอยู่
ประมาณ 4-5 หลังมีไม่ใช่ถ้านี้มี
กว่าตีไม่ได้ใช้เต็นท์ของอุทยานเหรอค่ะ
ไม่ได้ใช้เขาก็จะมีที่ให้ไปกลางเต็นท์ของ
คนที่เอาเต็นท์ไปเองค่ะๆ
ฉันเดินขึ้นไปเหนื่อยแล้วกันเต้นอีกแล้ว
อ่ะเหตุ
การณ์เต็นท์แป๊บเดียวเต้นหัวตี้กลางเร็ว
มากประมาณ 10 นาทีก็กางเสร็จเข้านอนได้
แล้วต่อถ้ากูอีกขอขอเต้นเข้ากลางไว้แล้ว
แล้วกันฮ่าๆ
กว่าจะแกะก็จะเก็บ
5  - ขอขึ้นมาถึงบนยอดภูกระดึงแล้วเรามี
เวลาเราก็เดินไปดูพระอาทิตย์ตกดินได้ครับ
เดี๋ยวขอถามนิดนึงนะฮะเขาขาวๆหมอกเต็ม
อย่างนี้ตลอดไหมคะ 555 ถ้าเป็นตอนเช้าก็
จะมีบอกแบบนี้ถ้าเราไปช่วงที่อากาศหนาว
มากๆก็จะมีหมอกแบบนี้ค่ะตอนที่ขวดอี้ไป
อากาศอุณหภูมิประมาณ 14 องศาก็น่าจะมี
หรอกเนาะใช่ครับแต่ว่ามีหมอกให้หน่อยตอน
นี้ตัวที่ไปมองนิดหน่อยไม่เยอะแต่ถ้าหนาว
หนาวกี่องศาหนาวถ้าสมมติ 14 แล้วเจอฝนตก
โอ้โห of คิด
ก็สนุก
ถ้าฝนตกแล้วนอนเต็นท์เนี่ยควรจะคิดว่าไม่
สนุก
เขาว่าจะเปียกไม่เปียกหรอกเต็นท์เอา
กระเช้าจะดีแต่มันจะเย็นๆทรายอ่าอ่ะโอเค
ค่ะแล้วก็กางเต้นท์เสร็จแล้วก็ไปรอดูพระ
อาทิตย์ตกดิน
นักเรียนพานี้รักความพยายามของคนไทย
เดินขึ้นภูเขาดูพระอาทิตย์ตกร 5 กับที่
ที่สวยที่สุดที่จะดูพระอาทิตย์ตกดินที่ภู
กระดึงต้องไปที่นี่ครับเวลาที่กดไปที่ภู
กระดึงเนี่ยต้องไปที่ตรงนี้ครับที่ไหนคะ
อ่าตรงนี้ครับพี่ปูผาหล่มสักขอชี้
ตรงไหนขึ้นตรงนี้หยุดทางนี้เป็นหน้าผาไส้
ครับอ่าเดี๋ยวเราที่ให้ดูตอนกลางวันนั้น
มีรูปตั้งค่าหน้านี่จะเป็นหน้าผาหน้าผา
คือจุดที่เรามองลงไปจะเป็นเป็นพื้นข้าง
ล่างเป็นเหวค่ะเอาใหม่นะผ่าคือตรงนี้
ตรงนั้นคนยืนได้กี่คนค่ะ
วันนี้คนก็คนก็จะไปเข้าไปยืนไม่กี่คน
เพราะว่าจะมีคนหลายๆคนเป็นรอรอรอคิวที่จะ
ไปยืนตรงนี้แล้วถ่ายรูป
เพราะฉะนั้นเขาก็จะมีเพื่อนๆที่ไปด้วยกัน
3  4 คนไปแล้วก็รอถ่ายรูปก็ถ่ายรูปเสร็จ
ก็ต้องออกมาคนอื่นก็เข้าไปถ่ายอ๋ออยู่ไหน
ไอ้ยาม
เคลื่อนที่คนคนที่ไปเที่ยวที่นั่นด้วยกัน
จะโกรธนะคะจะอยู่ไหนอ้าเพราะว่าต้องรอนาน
เงินเกินมาก็เหนื่อยแล้วต้องมารอถ่ายรูป
อีกค่ะหน้า
สวยมากใช่ค่ะก่อนตอนที่วันอาทิตย์กำลังจะ
ตกก็มีแสงสีส้มอยู่ขอบฟ้าก็ไปนั่งดูพระ
อาทิตย์ตกที่นี่ได้ว่าเป็นจุดชมวิวเลย
เป็นจุดชมวิวเป็นจุดที่ดูจุดไฮไลท์ที่นี่
เลยใช่ทุกอย่างนะฮะอะไรครับเห็นจังหวัด
เลยที่อยู่ข้างล่างค่าอยู่ข้างล่าง
ขึ้นไปถูกกระดิ่งแล้วไม่ถ่ายรูปตรงนี้ไม่
ถึงภูกระดึงหน่อยแล้วก็ไปไม่ถึงภูกระดึง
ครับค่า
R แล้วก็อ้าแล้วต้นไม้นั้นคือต้นสนหรือ
เปล่าค่ะเป็นต้นสนครับเป็นต้นสนใช่ครับ
ข้างบนจะมีต้นสนเยอะเพราะว่าข้างบนยอดภู
กระดึงอากาศค่อนข้างจะเย็นนะคนส่วนนี้ก็
จะโตได้ดีมากนะค่ะที่เย็นๆค่ะ
มีอะไรอีกหน้าแล้วก็ตอนเช้าครับตอนเช้า
เราก็มาอีกด้านหนึ่งของกูกระดึงรูปภาพคิด
ขึ้นไม่ใช่ตรงนี้ก็มีพระอาทิตย์ตกใช่ตรง
นี้ดูพระอาทิตย์ตกโอเคอ่าถ้าดูพระอาทิตย์
ขึ้นต้องไปดูอีกทีหนึ่งหน้ามาที่นี่ครับ
จากที่พักเดินไปไกลไว้หา
The อยู่บนนั้นก็ประมาณอ่า
2-3 กิโลครับไม่ไกลเท่าไหร่ค่ะ
กิโล Mega ยคู๋นี่
ที่พักอยู่ตรงไหนแล้วเดี๋ยวกูอ่ะตีรางวัล
ว่าที่ถ้าว่าโตขึ้นถึงจุดสีที่พักอยู่ตรง
นี้โอเคค่ะอ้าอาทิตย์ตกอยู่ตรงไหนคะ
อาทิตย์ตกอยู่ตรงนี้ครับ
อาทิตย์ตกจะทำงานแล้วค่ะอาทิตย์ขึ้นอยู่
ตรงไหนขึ้นอยู่ตรงนี้ครับอ๋ออ๋อโอเคมีทิศ
ตะวันออก
เริ่มถามเท่าที่ดูอ่ะถึงยอดแล้วเดินไปที่
พักนะ 4 กิโลกรัมแล้วเดินไปดูพระอาทิตย์
ตกกี่ 1 กิโลอ่ะ
ปลาที่ตกแต่ไกลมากแล้วจะใช้มากครับเค้าจะ
มารที่
ประมาณ 6 กิโลกรัม
2-3 กิโลมาดูพระอาทิตย์ขึ้นค่ะใส่ครับ
ตรงนี้ 4 กิโลเมตร
เดินสบายๆกับเดินคุยกันไปหาเขาเช้าๆเย็นๆ
ซ้อมเลย
นั้นต้องใช้เวลา 2 วันครับไปนอนไปนอนก่อน
เพราะว่าวันนี้เราเดินขึ้นมาตรงนี้ห้า
เกี่ยวเหนื่อยแล้วก็นอนก่อนคืนนึงค่ะนอน
สาวขนาดตอนเช้าเราก็เดินไปดูพระอาทิตย์
ขึ้นค่ะขอดูพระอาทิตย์ขึ้นเสร็จนะครับเรา
ก็กลับมานอนพักที่เต็นท์แล้วก็เดินไปดู
บ้านที่ตกถ้าใส่ครับแล้วก็กลับมานอนต่อ
กลับมานอนต่อล่ะอยู่วันเจริญก่อนยังลงไม่
ได้นะคะนักเรียนมืดแหละ
ๆเหมือนขึ้นแล้วลงไม่ได้เขาไม่ให้ลงครับ
ก็มาแล้วค่าโอเค
โอ้ยอยากไป
วันนี้เราไปภูกระดึงใช้เวลาเยอะมากเลย
กลัวติ๊กคิดว่าจะพาไปอีกที่หนึ่งเดี๋ยวนะ
ทันหรือเปล่ายังพอมีเวลาอยู่นิดหน่อยให้
ดูนิดหน่อยก็ได้ค่ะจริงๆจังหวัดเลยมีที่
ให้เที่ยวเยอะนะคะภูกระดึงน่ะเป็นอะไรที่
เวลาคุยแล้วสนุกแต่กูไม่ได้นานนะคะ
ถึงจังหวัดเลยก็คิดถึงภูกระดึงใช่ชายๆ
แล้วมีที่อื่นอีกหรอคะมีที่เที่ยวที่ไหน
อีกอย่างหนึ่งที่ถ้าเห็นสิ่งนี้จะต้องรู้
ทันทีเลยเลยแม่นอนอะไรที่ 5 คืออันนี้
ครับถ้าตอบผี
เป็นขี้มันได้สวยมาก
เป็นผีผีตาโขนค่าที่หักโหมเป็นเทศกาลที่
มีอยู่ที่จังหวัดเลยทีเดียวเท่านั้นชาย
ชายไปหาหมอเป็นสนุกสนานเนาะเช่นกันให้
นั้นเองกูเอกจะไม่ได้ว่าเดือนอะไรอ่ะผีตา
โขนจะมีประมาณช่วง 15 ค่ำเดือน 6  15 ค่ำ
เดือน 6 วันอะไร
ไม่ใช่มาคะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
[เพลง]
เดือนเดือนๆเดินประมาณเดือนกุมภาพันธ์ได้
วาเลนไทน์นะฮะมาคะจะเดือน 6 ค่ะ 5 ค่ำ
เดือน 6 วันมาฆะอุดอัลพีน่าขนก็จะมีหลัง
จากวันมาฆบูชานิดหน่อยค่ะวิสาขะ
วิสาคำ
หลังจากวันวิสาขบูชานิดหน่อยค่ะ
เราจะเป็นเทศกาลที่คนก็จะออกมาแต่งตัว
เป็นผี
น้ำเงินบนถนนนะครับค่ะเคยทำหน้าผีตาเหมาะ
สมด้วยนะเหรอครับ
ขี้ยากไหม
ใช้ใบใช้ไอ้นั่นน่ะค่ะกาพย์ของต้นไม้อ่ะ
ค่ะแล้วก็มาวาดรูปมามาแกะตาว่าดูใส่หนัง
ยางคู่เอกทำเองเลยขอเพลงอยากทำสนุกว่า
สนุกมากจะไม่ได้ไปทำที่เลยนะคะทำที่ลง
แล้วก็อ๋อ
อ่าหน้ากากของผีตาโขนเนี่ยเขาจะใช้ใช้บวช
ในการทำข้างบนแล้วหัวหาได้ครับนี่ครับทำ
มาจากขวดขวดเนี่ยจะเป็นอ่ะที่ที่คนที่ศาล
เขาจะกินข้าวเหนียวใช่มั้ยใช่กินข้าว
เหนียวเขาก็ใช้หัวนะครับในการหุงข้าว
เหนียวค่ะว่าเอาเมื่อวางไว้ข้างบนถ่ายชาย
เอาหัวน้อยข้างบนก็เป็นหน้ากากผีตาโขนนี่
เองอ่ะส่วนข้างหน้าน่าจะเป็นเป็นเป็นอ่ะ
เป็นกราบของต้นไม้มาฮาๆชื่อของต้นไม้เขา
จะงงงอ๋อพอดีค่ะแล้วก็ล็อคพอดีวาดรูปได้
หรืออ๋อเป็นหน้ากากส่าทำเป็นรูปผีนะครับ
ใส่ตัวแทนของความไม่ดีความโชคร้ายนะครับ
หลังจากที่เขาเขามีการเดินขบวนแล้วก็แห่
ผีตาฝนไปเนี่ยเวลาจบงานแล้วเนี่ยเขาก็จะ
เอาหน้ากากอย่างไปทิ้งแม่น้ำเพราะหรอหา
ใต้ครับ 5 วิธีในแม่น้ำเพราะว่าถือว่า
เป็นสิ่งที่ไม่ดีให้ให้ออกไปจากตัวเราค่ะ
อ้าไงครับยังไม่เคยเห็นของจริงเหมือนกัน
นะกูอ่ะพี่เคยเห็นของจริงแล้วยังควรที่
เคยเห็นของจริงกว่าทิ้งเอ้ยไอ้ที่เลย
เหมือนกันค่ะ
น่าสนใจเป็นเทศกาลที่สนุกค่ะนะคะ
มีเขาจะแห่กันใช้เวลา 3 วัน
3 วันเลยเหรอคะแต่วันที่มีกี่ตาโขนจะมี
แค่วันเดียวอ๋อค่ะวันแรกก็จะเป็นเรื่อง
ของการเตรียมพิธีมีการบวชพระด้วยอ๋อค่ะ
วันที่ 2 ก็จะมีแห่ผีตาโขนค่ะวันที่ 3 ก็
จะมีการเทศน์เทศน์เพื่อสอนธรรมะว่าเมื่อ
วานที่แห่ผีตาโขนเนี่ยเขาจะกำจัดสิ่งที่
ชั่วร้ายออกไปแล้วค่าาวันมีสติและมีฟัง
เพศถ้า
เป็นประเพณีของชาวจังหวัดเลยกันหาวิชา
เพาะที่เลยนะคะถ้ายังครับมีเลยเท่านั้น
อ่าโอเคครับทองก็โอเคจริงๆเลยมีอีกเยอะนะ
คะมีหลายที่น่าสนใจ
ฟังเพลิน
เอาไปเที่ยวกับครัวติ้งไม่เหนื่อยพอไม่
ต้องเดินเอง
ให้กลัวแต่ไม่เดินแล้วมันเล่าให้นักเรียน
ปังนะครับบายค่ะโอเคค่ะคืนนี้มีเวลาแล้ว
นะคะเดี๋ยวเรากลับมาเจอกันใหม่คราวหน้าจะ
พาไปเที่ยวที่ไหนคอยติดตามกันนะครับท่า
อิฐลาไปก่อนแล้วครับน่ะสวัสดีครับครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะกว่าตีสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนบ๊ายบาย